[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wow
super könnte so schon bald die Zukunft
aussehen Renato Jordan will auf seiner
ehemaligen Schafweide oberhalb von Gondo
im oberwalles auf 2000 m über Meer Strom
im großen Stil produzieren zum ersten
Mal soll im hochalpinen Gelände ein
Solarpark in der freien Natur entstehen
ein Pionierprojekt das wistand
wet also wir s jetzt hier
mal und hier entstäte die solaranlag da
ober ist die italienische Grenze da ob s
wir schon in Italien und die anlag die
entsteht hier da
nachher hier die ganze gagend bis da
ganz ganz
wie das sind ungefähr 100
qu da nachher mit peletzt
[Musik]
sind in diesem Film möchte ich
herausfinden warum dieser Mann
pensionierter Gymnasiallehrer und
Geograph nun noch solarpionier werden
will ja das Renato
Jordan Sch mit mit dem mit dem
Kamerateam da machen sch geht es nach
Jordan soll dieses Kraftwerk in seinem
Projekt eine wichtige Rolle
spielen golar hier will er die
Sonnenenergie von gondos Solar
einspeisen gondosolar so nennt er die
geplante Anlage also da ist der ruer das
da und da oben das gibt zwe stürfe und
nacher hin da ist derung das ist der Ort
war wir gondosolar W installieren die
fotovoltaikanlag der alung ein kleiner
Flecken für große Pläne 14 Fußballfelder
groß soll nämlich die gesamte Anlage
werden die Visualisierung zeigt die
ganze Größe des
Solarparks für sein sonnenprojekt ist
Renato Jordan selbst auf nach
Sonnenuntergang unterwegs an diesem
Abend tritt an einem Anlass auf
diete Frauen Lobbyarbeit denn er braucht
möglichst bald die baubewähigung vom
Kanton
Wallis Fossil ist ke lesig als Geograph
m ich sagen das ist immer m Ziel sage
dass wir Ken doch nicht Material oder
Grundstoffe war 60 Millionen Jahr
gebrüt vor 200 Millionen Jahr wir doch
die einfach in on oder vier Generationen
einfach verbrennen V der AR der alung
das ist die gagend da wir g solarwelle
machen es ist das Hochplateau das
hochplate ist 2 me mer und hcher das
heißt da ist atmosphäa sehr dünn und son
die da uninder die da durchg das ist ein
riesiger
Vorteil wenn wir da die offizielle
nabelk geh von der schwitz das ist die
offizielle allerdings aber das ist die
offizielle kte der nach das verglichen
mit dem daher das ist die
bevölkersdichte Bundesamt für Statistik
203 und da se Meister Lied die wnen da
und da mE Lied wohnen das sind am Mete
Gebäude und da mE Gebäude sind da hat
dacher und da hat Fassade das ist doch
logisch oder so das überall Nebel außer
im W das ist nicht
sondern das ist das Bild Meteo Schweiz V
26 Januar
20 im Publikum befinden sich
Gemeinderätinnen großrätinnen und auch
der mitteständerat be Reder aus dem
Wallis ist anwesend Reder hat ein
nationales solargesetz in Bern
durchgeboxt wir bis 2025 Strom
produziert erhält bis zu 60% der Kosten
vom Bund zurückerstattet Jordans Projekt
ist unter
Zeitdruck
mer ich Gefühl dass ich Publikum
erreicht das mirentlich aller
wichtig Begriff V was es geht und was
mir geht
jetzt wir s wir s wir schaffen
wir super WE
das
aber vorell ja das
hervorrag ja wir m all
machen
Renato Jordans Projekt hat die
Diskussion um alpine Solaranlagen in der
Schweiz
angestoßen mir scheint seine Mission die
Leute zu überzeugen sei an diesem Abend
gelungen es ist im vergich zu
anderenlagüberag das W vielleicht auch
die erst und den kann auch als
Pilotprojekt Gel also da wir drüber
reden aber wenn man jetzt über komagen
in unberührter Landschaft das G für mich
nicht also ganz ehrlich
bege sehr gut vorgebrungen und sind ganz
ganz logische
Argument Punkt bringen geht nich gr
Strom alle brü Strom und war Strom her
und
Luft sehr
über dass ein Projekt längst nicht alle
begeistert davon später mehr im Bergdorf
Gondo im Kanton Wallis beim Simplon Pass
wächst Renato Jordan auf ein Steinwurf
zur Grenze Italiens für Renato Jordan
eine prägende Kindheit eng verbunden mit
dem Dorf und der Natur in seinen Träumen
so sagt mir der 72-Jährige Kehre er fast
jede Nacht an seinen Heimatort zurück
wer von hier kommt hat schon früh
erfahren welche Naturgewalten auf die
Erde
wirken
das da hier sehr spezieller Ort da war
der P
ist genau
daestand und das ist Katastrophe vüber
20 Jahr ist das mit samtum
Fundament NS mE ein Erdrutsch zerstört
ein Drittel des wallisser grenzdörfchens
und reiß 13 Menschen in den Tod dieser
schwarze Tag hat in Gondo bis heuteef
Spur
Renato Jordan und seine vier Geschwister
leben zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr in
Gondo auch sein Vater hielt sich in
einem anderen Teil des Dorfes auf und
überlebte das
Unglück h wichtige Sache so nich
gefunden genau hier
hier und natürlich weiß ich nch ganz
genau wie er das Zimmer we ich alles
sammen aber emotional ist hier nichts
mehr
ja sein Leben hat viele Facetten
Geograph pensionierter Gymnasiallehrer
Familienvater Künstler und nun auch
solarpionier die Energieproduktion war
schon immer wichtig für die Gemeinde
Gondo zwischbergen bereits seit über 70
Jahren produziert man hier Strom aus
erneuerbaren
Energien mal das das ist der
blauputz und da hin da wir immer oben
auf der Höhle Brick man ganzen Detail V
dem V dem se se das ist einach ganz
verruckt jährlich produzieren in der
Region drei Wasserkraftwerke Strom für R
57 000 Haushalte im Durchschnitt nimmt
die kleine Berggemeinde damit eine
Million Franken durch Wasserzinsen
ein es ist eine raue Gegend ein enges
Tal trotzdem hat man hier Visionen für
die ganze Schweiz Renato Jordan will wie
die Generationen vor ihm auch schon in
das Geschäft der Energieproduktion
einsteigen
nurseld es geht mir nicht nur g
verdienen also ich die Idee Amfang und
ich nicht an das ged für mich ist
natürlich ganz wichtig dass man von den
fossile wekt das ist für mich et vom
wichtigste und es kan ja nicht Sie dass
wir ardö war 60 Millionen Jahre
entstanden ist dass wir das in innerhalb
v d vi Generationen einfach
Verbrennen
der und die Generation war nachher
kommen dieach drackige umwal und ke ke
Rohstoff mehr das geht einfach nicht das
ist ein von der HT dr und natürlich muss
ich sagen GAL ist natürlichrie das ist
klar inzwischen wohnt Renato Jordan mit
seiner Familie in der Talebene in Brick
hier hat der pensionierte
Gymnasiallehrer und Künstler sein
Atelier beschäftigt sich im Moment vor
allem mit digitaler Kunst
was ist der zammenhang von der Kunst
undter Energie
gehtam ich glaube dass in der Kunst brü
man gewisse Kreativität D das kann
machen und ich GL
halt dass man h in der Situation W wir
energetisch g in schwitz oder dass man
Fantasie kreative L sind die ganze fing
initiativri für so geh ja nich wenn nich
n
steht also W nicht immer n auf dem war
ichie dem ich vorfah gemacht nicht immer
auf dem B und nachher sag es ke entwickl
m
[Musik]
Entwick das Sonnenlicht ist an diesem
Morgen noch weit weg ich begleite Renato
Jordan und seine Leute an einem für sie
wichtigen Tag seit Monaten haben sie
dafür gearbeitet jetzt steht oben auf
dem Berg eine Testanlage er sieht sie
heute zum ersten
Mal
halbw sehr
wenig aber ja
die Bri nach simplorf und in simplorf
erwartet der Helikopter ich
naching
[Musik]
wirelle Jordan und die beiden ngenieure
überprüfen die hochalpine Testanlage es
muss alles stimmen damit diese Wind
Wetter und vor allem den Winter
[Musik]
übersteht auf
R
[Musik]
die üsicht hier das ichach phänomenal
wunderbar die Standortvorteile auf
dieser Höhe wenig Nebel und im Winter
reflektiert der Schnee zusätzlich auf
die Panels gerade in der kalten
Jahreszeit produziert eine solche Anlage
bis zu vierm mehr als im melland das war
dieanl da geht drum dass man l wie der
Wind und wir wir das da
verhaltet wir dass das da WS der die
stärkste Wind sind und wenn die
testanlag
dasicher weniger
Wind früher brachte die familieord dies
al zukünftig sollen hier Solarelemente
Strom für rund 4500 Haushalte liefern es
ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt von
Initiant Renato Jordan der Gemeinde
Gondo zwischbergen und eines lokalen
Stromerzeugers dessen Hauptaktionär der
Stromkonzern alpig ist ist das so
machbar mit dem BoD das da
ist
schwierig das geht ja
die eingesetzten Solarzellen sind
bifaial das heißt die Panels können
beidseitig Sonnenenergie aufnehmen dies
sei auf Hausdächern und Fassaden kaum
möglich Kosten fürs Gesamtprojekt rund
50 Millionen Schweizer Franken
Unterstützungsgelder des Bundes sind
zwingend nötig sonst rechnet sich der
Solarpark nicht das ist die
Gesamtübersicht
die
nachwoh hier auf der K
ja ja aber wir aber nicht hier ja ja h
aber
das will die SAG sogar wenn da ob
lawiina z dem gebt dass die sogar wieder
hier ob ja se das aber die kom alle 300
Jahre mal g W aber
D 300
jah ja aber 300 Jahr das das n hier ja
ja hier so schlimm aber
hier
was und wir sch die künstlich aber da
aber Italien aber
und ja was ist jetzt Schwierigkeit mit
Lawine ja Schwierigkeit ist wiss wie wie
wi oder wie noch das lawiina komm und
wie noch das der lawin Druck und was für
lawin hab sind das feslawine od
stblwine das ist jetzt noch in
klarig mit
dem hier
ist ne ne jetzt mach
warm
ja n fr das ke Wind ja ja ja solch eine
Anlage zu bauen das ist Pionierarbeit
die Erschließung der
hochgebirgsbaustelle mit zwei temporären
Seilbahnen die Topographie und die
extremen Bedingungen fordern die
Ingenieure ja also die die groß
Challenge istatfer wird die
allag wirk künftig auf die auf die auf
der Wind und auf die Schnee
verfrachtigge wenn nachher die
das die oberflach Struktur verer und das
kan wirk auf die
Schnee also im dum Fall nach in schne
drin jetzt
nicht
ganz
[Musik]
gen bereit seit Jahren ist ein kleines
Team an der Planung alpig hat bisher
mehrere hertaus Franken ins Projekt
gesteckt doch wer unberührte Natur
bebauen will muss mit Widerstand aus dem
Natur und Landschaftsschutz rechnen will
wir aber sorgfaltig schaffen und
wirklich schon lang hin sie Flora und
Fauna und Geologie und all naturfah so
un Gefühl dass wir will wir
Diezi dass wir da der
Stand Rückhalt erhält Renato Jordan von
seiner Heimatgemeinde Gondo zwischbergen
hier hat es Tradition mit Strom Geld zu
verdienen das Dorf steht finanziell so
gut da dass es einen Teil der
Krankenkasse der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
bezahlt an der rurversammlung sind die
Meinungen zu GOND Solar
gemacht
Punkt das Projekt unterstütz wer ist wir
machen
stim Punkt
Projek el mal
sch volle Unterstützung fürs Projekt von
der Heimatgemeinde doch kräftigen
Widerstand gibt's von anderer
[Musik]
Seite Umweltschützerin Vera Weber und
ihre Stiftung stellen sich in der
Öffentlichkeit gegen alpine
Solarprojekte sie ist die Präsidentin
der Fundation Franz Weber und will sich
persönlich ein Bild vor Ort machen auf
Einladung von Reporter wandert sie zur
abgelegenen
Weide was erwarten sie jetzt wenn wir da
oben ko Solar erreichen also ich ich
denke das wird eine einmalige Landschaft
sein eine intakte Landschaft sein so wie
ich das auf Fotos gesehen habe und so
wie ich das von Berichten her kenne und
so Landschaften muss man intakt behalten
da darf nichts gebaut werden weil unsere
Landschaften in der Schweiz sind schon
jetzt sehr
begrenzt der alpirung liegt weit weg von
der Zivilisation eine Bergtour von
zweieinhalb Stunden da muss man
schwindelfrei
sein
bereits wa Webers Vater Franz Weber hat
sich als Initiant der
Zweitwohnungsinitiative für den
Landschaftsschutz
eingesetzt wir müssen einfach die
Menschen sensibilisieren die Menschen
informieren und aufzeigen dass es andere
Wege gibt und andere gebe Wege geben
muss weil
das können sie mir nicht sagen dass es
schön ist auch wenn das jetzt Holz
ist wir haben in der Raumplanung im
Naturschutzgesetz so viele
ungenschaften gekriegt in den letzten
Jahrzehnten und jetzt will man alles
über Bord werfen auf der auf dem Altar
der der Energiekrise und des
Klimaschutzes man darf die Umwelt den
Umweltschutz und den Naturschutz nicht
mit dem Klimaschutz ausspielen das
dürfen wir nicht akzeptieren nicht
ausspielen trotzdem was ist dann die
Lösung für den winterstrom den wir ja
nur hier oben und nicht auf dem en
produzieren könen also es gibt in sehr
vielen höher gelegene Orte gibt es schon
Infrastrukturen auch in Berggebiete auch
bei den bei den Bergstationen da könnte
man wirklich auch mit solarpaneln diese
schon bebaute stark bebaute Gebiete mit
Solar Solarpanels bestücken und eben die
Dächer in diesen hohen hohen Lagen
bestücken mit solarpenel und nicht die
freien Natur die intakte Natur zu
pflastern die Gegenseite ist überzeugt
dass es auch Gund Solar braucht um
genügend Strom zu produzieren zudem habe
ein solarforscher den Standort als sehr
geeignet für die Stromproduktion
[Musik]
eingeschätzt
Renato Jordan und Vera Weber haben sich
noch nie persönlich
getroffen bei diesem Dreh von SF
Reporter sehen sich die beiden zum
ersten
Mal fre
Michi ihen auf dies W baren Fleck
Schweizer Landschaft ein Traum Traum
wirklich schön ja und jetzt wir mal
unterhalten best so hier sitzen
und
Bildschirm kann ich mehrere Sachen jetzt
da zeigen der Professor das befindet
sich an einer sehr gut geeigneten Lage
und könnte eine alpine Photovoltaik
Anlage in diesem Gebiet zu einem
nationalen Vorzeigeprojekt mit einer
Ausstrahlung weit über die Landesgrenzen
hinaus werden und die Betonsockel
und
betotovolic Panel sind nicht recyclebar
in dem doch das alles recyclebar W ist
da informiert treffe ist regelmäßig mit
der Umweltverband das sind die vier
Verband das ist der stifftte
landschaftsschutzschwitz her steer WWF
bronatura und neuerings mountain
wildernis wir sind nicht Teil von diesem
von dieser Gruppe die sie da gezeigt
haben und aber wir sind immer offen g
aber vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
für für für diese kurze sehr
eindrückliche Präsentation mer ja
wünsche ich Ihnen alles Gute alles GTE
Frau vion auf jeden Fall schön
danke hat die gar nichtrecht
se gar nichts
gebren ob wa Weber gegen das Projekt
Einsprache erheben wird ist noch offen
auf meine Nachfrage mochte sie keine
klare Antwort geben sicher ist jedoch
dass ihre Stiftung das Referendum gegen
das nationale Stromversorgungsgesetz
unterstützt kommt es zustande und wird
vom Volk angenommen könnt es für alle
zukünftigen alpinen Solarprojekte
schwierig
[Musik]
werden
jer da
will du kannst
[Musik]
weißenon
diew Renato Jordan Vertreter der
Gemeinde und der
energieunternehmung der Druck auf die
Verantwortlichen steigt ein
überparteiliches komite will schnellere
baubewigungsverfahren für Solarprojekte
verhindern es wird zur Abstimmung
kommen
es zeichnet sich ab Strom zu produzieren
bis
2025 wird knapp das ist Ziel und das ist
erreichbar aber
klar das ist dass
die kommt und das
Material
so der letzte gibt's natürlich immer
wieder riesig aber das Ziel hab schon
das wir wieder lecker dass das der nicht
so
[Musik]
ist die Eingabe der baubeewlligung wird
sich verzögern nach einer Auswertung
ordnen die Ingenieure die Solarmodule
neu an solarbäume soll es nun geben dem
Wald rundherum nachempfunden sie seinen
gleich effizient gliederten sich aber
besser in die Landschaft
[Musik]
ein züige Solarzelle in Alpe versum ist
das alpträum und ein verschand von der
Natur für andere ein N brag für
energieversorg am 10 September stimmt Z
Erfolg dr ob die buwiigung verfahre
verstige Fotovoltaik Großlage s
verschnellert
werde es ist der Tag der Wahrheit für
Renato Jordans Projekt die kantonale
Abstimmung wird für die ganze Schweiz
wegweisend
sein eigentlich möchte er den Tag
alleine verbringen doch ich darf ihn mit
der Kamera begleiten wenn die große
Entscheidung
fällt und mit der üh
geh g Gefühl aber ich re natürlich mit
allem das ist demokratische Abstimmung
und da MS halt einfach das alle
ke
Prognose keine
hoffn Prognose keine hoffn
[Applaus]
ja
ab 12 Uhr gibt es die ersten
[Musik]
Resultate also die gem zge die
abgestimmt das mir jetzt gerade der
Präsident Verg geschrieben
und solarkret zu 100% ja
schon mal schon
[Musik]
mal doch die Freude W nicht
lange das zw klar ne geht es wird es
gehtfach n super ist
tstimmig ist alles
gezählt also es ist 6
ABG ein Nein zu schnelleren
Baubewilligungsverfahren ja was
will ja ist wirklich schlecht als
zeicher ja
ja
machenüberhol binlich ja F pinlich ja
wir W eigentlichfangen mit dem ganzen
und ja genau und jetzt ist ist halt das
einfach so nach außen wirkt Renato
Jordan trotz der Niederlage gefasst aber
ich merke dass er enttäuscht ist
ja ja iche schon nicht fre ehrlich fre
aber aber es mich nicht hinder die Idee
witer ich will das wier machen und
wirnen wir
K das Ziel bis 2025 Strom zu produzieren
ist fraglich aufgeben ist für den
solarpionier keine
Option